C Mr Man inry was here he he put his
hands on me I wanted to call the police
but I know what you said about them in
the past that that that we had to be
careful let calm down I can
explain he asked my permission to visit
you and you gave
it I did Clarence would like to court
you since when you call him
Clarence I'm sorry if he came on too
strong where did he get the idea that he
could Court me when I'm not even old
enough to date the only way I can get us
all to death and to protect our home is
through this
marriage
marriage what happened to courton me
I've been asking about you for some time
now I put him off as long as I could I
just warm up to
him show him that you're
trying don't do this to
me
please I wish there was another
[Music]
way